bah alors aujourd'hui c'est un grand
jour
parce que c'est
ça nous fait de la peine
c'est la dernière de la saison de
Delphine Wespiser
tout de suite alors tout va bien mais
Delphine on peut on peut on peut
raconter ce qui se passe
professionnellement pour toi
Delphine je vous raconte
a été appelé
pour animer une nouvelle émission c'est
bon ça je suis s'il vous plait si je
veux parler vous ne faites pas de
commentaire
laisse-moi finir et après vous parlerez
tout ce que vous voudrez parler dans les
sujets on a besoin de VOUS là on a pas
besoin
donc Delphine il se présente Delphine
Wespiser
mon nom de famille
le Boulard elle a pris un Boulard
non mais elle a pris non mais elle a
pris la grosse tête alors je vous
explique
il y a une nouvelle émission qui va
arriver sur W9 c'est pas quand je sais
pas où et voilà
voilà
je donnerai pas mon avis c'est une autre
j'ai une autre chaîne qui s'appelle
loveil voilà après on regardera pas et
on aime beaucoup Delphine
on verra pas on aime beaucoup Delphine
donc Delphine m'a demandé il m'a dit je
suis en lice pour peut-être animer le
vaillante
je lui ai dit vas-y fonce d'accord
ici tu peux repartir revenir ça va je
suis très content que tu sois là quand
tu es là et quand tu es pas là ça chute
pas non plus
toujours la vérité c'est
pour ça que tu le sais moi je pense
d'abord à toi franchement c'est très
bien pour toi fais-toi plaisir tu vas
pouvoir partir en vacances tu vas être
payé non mais c'est vrai franchement tu
vas être là tu vas faire du pédalo et
puis c'est tout et puis ce sera payé par
quelqu'un d'autre moi je suis très
heureux non mais je l'ai dit franchement
vas-y il y a aucun problème vas-y s'il
me donne peut-il me demande pas d'argent
il y a pas de problème donc delphine a
été prise
j'ai eu les patrons notamment
le grand patron de M6 on s'est vu et on
a dit les
c'est serré la main on s'est dit c'est
bon tu peux prendre Delphine il y a
aucun problème
si et notamment Nicolas taverno est
vraiment un ami j'aime beaucoup on
s'entend très très bien Jérôme Foucret
W9 aussi c'est vraiment un ami donc
Jérôme j'ai eu Nicolas j'ai eu tout le
monde j'ai eu le producteur également
thierry lachkerque est un ami aussi
voilà donc il y a eu tous les amis qui
m'ont appelé j'ai dit les mecs faites ce
que vous voulez mais vous savez que vous
m'envoyez une voilà
c'est tout à un moment voilà je leur
demande un truc je sais pas encore quoi
on verra mais j'aurai un truc à demander
on verra on verra voilà on verra il le
savent ils l'ont dans la tête ils me
connaissent et ça voilà très bien mais
avant tout je l'ai fait
parce que Delphine ça lui faisait
plaisir
bien sûr qu'elle avait envie donc je lui
ai dit et après elle m'a dit ouais mais
je suis Fort Royal
je lui ai dit fort Boyard je peux
m'arranger
pour Fort Boyard également
donc elle a pu faire elle va faire le
Island Fort Boyard TPMP
[Rires]
donc comment vous dire que je suis un
des hommes les plus heureux de France
je vais vous dire franchement je vais
vous dire et je vais vous dire je le
problème que j'ai c'est que je dis
toujours la vérité
Delphine elle sera toujours la bienvenue
ici et bien sûr qu'elle a sa place en
septembre ici avec nous avec grand
plaisir maintenant faut savoir il faut
savoir quitter la table quand le
meilleur est des sérieux
Charles Aznavour non non après Delphine
je suis très heureux pour elle il y aura
certainement une deuxième saison de la
Thaïlande elle fera la deuxième saison
mais voilà on a un accord avec W9 elles
peuvent venir pour partir voilà elle
peut elle fait ce qu'elle veut c'est
très bien voilà donc ça nous dérange pas
parce que c'est des amis ça se passe
bien voilà comme ça se passe très bien
avec le groupe M6 ça va ça vient ça va
ça vient voilà après voilà il faudrait
je demande un petit billet c'est pas
voilà ce qui m'arranger c'est que quand
elle vient dans TPMP c'est soit eux qui
prennent la prestation
c'est comme vous savez quand on est au
restaurant on sait pas qui va payer tu
vois voilà voilà bon j'ai fait un geste
voilà
au restaurant le plus riche qui paye
c'est le plus riche qui paye donc là du
coup ça se passe comment ben non mais je
sais pas dans le cas présent
pour W9
[Rires]
et vous alors
c'est quoi
ça va ça va on trouvera
vous inquiétez pas on trouvera mais ça
faisait plaisir à Delphine donc Delphine
ils ont communiqué le vallon de varier
bientôt et j'ai dit à Delphine ce soir
on va faire la dernière et amuse-toi
fais-toi plaisir et bien sûr elle sera
pour l'instant il y a aucun souci elle
est de retour en septembre fin août même
je crois qu'on reprendra le 25 août je
crois que j'ai vu la dernière fois avec
la chaîne là c'est le 25 ah non 4
septembre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais 4 septembre
et
ouais je suis très heureuse c'est un
nouveau défi je pense que c'est une
belle évolution je pense que j'ai 31 ans
je pense que je suis prête à montrer ce
que je sais faire et des gens en ce
moment me font confiance et ont envie de
moi donc ça me fait très plaisir
comme tout le monde voilà mais c'est
tout mais ça sera très bien mais
Delphine
bien sûr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
on pense à Daniel Moreau sur le
vaillante
j'ai pas encore eu énormément d'appels
on va pas se raconter d'histoires
je peux y aller ou pas
[Applaudissements]
donc Delphine amuse-toi et on te revoit
à la rentrée et bien entendu on te
suivra dans la rue
tout seul tu vas pas nous faire chier en
tout cas ça me fait beaucoup d'émotions
cette dernière même si c'est pas une
dernière définitive parce que vraiment
le comment dire l'ambiance l'énergie et
l'adrénaline qu'on a sur cette émission
on la retrouve nulle part d'autres et
quoi qu'il en soit
parce qu'on sait pas à l'avenir et bien
sûr voilà tout va bien mais je voulais
vraiment vous dire que que quand j'étais
dans ma région en Alsace et que je
faisais uniquement Fort Boyard et que
les gens me connaissaient que pour
blanche et pour rouge bah c'est vous qui
avez su révélé Delphine vous m'avez pris
sous votre aile et vous me protéger et
merci beaucoup vraiment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
le plus sympa des patrons c'est moi je
le pense vraiment en plus vraiment de
télé c'est moi je le pense vraiment je
le pense je le pense vraiment parce que
voilà moi je dis les choses
c'est même produit je vous le dis c'est
même pas moi
qui encore ça aurait été moi dis bon à
la limite même pas rien zéro
vous avez
on peut prendre
il y a des remplaçants qui arriveront
dès la semaine prochaine qui sont
actuellement voilà
qui me demande qu'une chose c'est donner
leur avis sur le monde actuel sur la
société et elles seront là dès que
l'avion nous permettra voilà de de les
faire arriver voilà ne vous inquiétez
pas la musique d'opération
séduction
alors ça sera pas du poste pour poste ça
peut très bien être Daniel Moreau qui
remplace Delphine
Moreau bascule là-bas et que moi je
récupère une demoiselle et bien moi je
suis bien bah c'est ce que je vais faire
pour brouiller les pistes
il faudra Daniel Moreau avec les tenues
de Delphine
[Rires]
vous partez en danse orientale après
directement ou pas c'est très joli hein
en tout cas c'est sa dernière et je
voudrais dire merci aussi à la chaîne
qui a bien voulu voilà ils ont appris
hier ils ont été hyper sympa
[Musique]
et merci à eux parce qu'ils ont été
d'une compréhension incroyable et ils
ont dit Delphine revient quand elle veut
elle était adorable et justement j'avais
la chaîne cet après-midi au téléphone
ils m'ont dit on te souhaite vraiment le
meilleur et que et si ça se passe pas
bien tu es toujours tu es toujours la
bienvenue de retour à la maison
c'est pas comme ça avant
de conneries qui peuvent venir aux gens
pour s'en débarrasser
je connais l'échelle
aussi
t'inquiète pas tu reviens quand tu veux
j'ai dû essayer de racheter pour revenir
un petit peu hein
vraiment Delphine c'est la famille la
famille de la famille elle vient quand
elle veut et de toute façon elle va
revenir elle a fait le Island ils vont
pas ça sera pas toute l'année
pourquoi ben parce que c'est exactement
dans le même timing tous les soirs
et c'est bien tu as choisi d'aller sur
une émission qui n'est pas regardé c'est
tout choix
non mais c'est vrai écoute c'est ton
choix je connais les chiffres à 19h non
non non
mais j'ai les médias métriques qui fait
très bien au travail on sait que maison
elle a par exemple tu vois hier les
apprentis aventuriers ça fait 400000
téléspectateur il vaut mieux 400000
téléspectateurs assidus que 2 millions
qui nous regardent tous les jours merci